salut les épicurieuses et les épicurieux
lampe sac en plastique stylo brosse à
dents joué récipient ventilateur tous
ces objets ont un point commun ils sont
en plastique partiellement ou totalement
[Musique]
légère et pas cher cette matière est
omniprésente dans notre quotidien et en
particulier dans les emballages même
l'écran dans lequel vous me regardez
contient du plastique dans les années 80
le groupe Elmer Food Beach chantait le
plastique c'est fantastique
ce matériau constitue une source de
pollution importante chaque année plus
de 8 millions de tonnes de plastique
finissent dans les mers et les océans
alors un monde sans plastique est-il
possible on va répondre à cette question
avec quelqu'un que vous connaissez bien
et qui s'exprime souvent sur ce genre de
sujet Chris de la chaîne poisson fécond
salut les amis bon pas la peine de faire
de grands discours en France on est
clairement accro au plastique et chaque
année nous utilisons 5 millions de
tonnes de plastique ça représente
quasiment 70 kg par habitant et ben les
emballages ménagers seul en représente
un quart mais le problème c'est que les
plastiques mettent des centaines
d'années à des composés par exemple 20
ans pour un sac plastique ou 450 ans
pour une bouteille en PET et du coup le
plastique c'est loin d'être fantastique
l'autre problème c'est que l'on retrouve
le plastique dans les mers et dans les
océans vous avez sûrement déjà entendu
parler du vortex de déchets du Pacifique
Nord des milliards de particules de
plastique se retrouvent en suspension et
Florent ce que l'on appelle aussi le
septième continent sa taille est estimée
à 1,6 millions de kilomètres carrés je
sais pas si vous vous rendez compte ça
représente quasiment trois fois la
taille de la France métropolitaine mais
du coup comment en est-on arrivé là
on commence à produire du plastique de
manière industrielle après la Première
Guerre mondiale c'est ainsi
qu'apparaissent les premiers caoutchouc
synthétiques le nylon les poignets de
casseroles isolantes l'industrie
chimique est alors en pleine expansion
et les gisements de pétrole et de gaz
avec lesquels on produit le plastique se
multiplie le grand boom a lieu dans les
années 50 avec l'avènement de la société
de consommation à cette époque la
production mondiale de plastique est à
peu près de 2 millions de tonnes par an
c'est très peu comparé à aujourd'hui on
est aux alentours de 400 millions de
tonnes alors les raisons de son succès
sont multiples notamment pour les
emballages c'est un matériau stérile les
bactéries ne se développent pas dessus
idéal donc pour conserver les aliments
il est léger résistant et pas cher donc
accessible et puis on peut en faire ce
que l'on veut il est aussi facilement
transportable tenez par exemple les
bouteilles autrefois en verre laisse
place aux bouteilles en plastique plus
légères et moins fragile rapidement ont
pris les vues comme la solution revers
de la médaille les plastiques produisent
des déchets qui jetés dans la nature
peuvent mettre des centaines d'années à
se désintégrer ce qui engendre de graves
problèmes de pollution avec des
conséquences désastreuses sur la faune
et la flore et ce n'est pas tout le
plastique est fabriqué à partir de
pétrole une énergie fossile qui n'est
pas renouvelable et dont les réserves
diminuent inexorablement sans compter
que la destruction du plastique par
combustion émet de grandes quantités de
CO2 l'un des principaux gaz à effet de
serre responsables du réchauffement
climatique il faut donc en utiliser le
moins possible et le recycler d'un point
de vue énergétique sont recyclage permet
de faire des économies de pétrole
conséquentes vous donnez une idée
recycler une tonne de bouteilles permet
d'économiser
830 litres de pétrole avec une bouteille
en PET on peut refaire la même bouteille
en PET en sachant que ces bouteilles
contiennent en moyenne
25% de PET recyclé et ça peut aller
jusqu'à 100% le problème c'est que
malheureusement 100% des plastiques ne
sont pas recyclables pour entrer dans
les détails les plastiques qui peuvent
se recycler sont déjà les polyéthylène
terrife thalates à vos souhaits les
polyéthylène haute densité donc vous
savez les fameux pet PEHD associés à des
numéros de 1 à 6 pour faire plus simple
on parle ici du coup de bouteilles d'eau
de gel douche ou même de liquide
vaisselle bref tout cela est bel et bien
recyclable et voici comment ça se passe
la première étape elle se passe chez
vous oui parce que bah c'est votre bac
de tri qui permet de lancer le processus
une fois collecté puis séparés par
matériaux les cartons d'un côté
l'aluminium de l'autre les différents
emballages plastiques arrivent dans une
autre usine pour les bouteilles par
exemple elles sont broyées en paillettes
puis laver pour retirer les étiquettes
et c'est grâce à ces fameuses paillettes
que le plastique va pouvoir être
réutilisé pour fabriquer de nouveaux
objets avec le pet on fabrique aussi des
emballages alimentaires on le recycle en
bouteille en flacon ou en barquettes et
ça sert aussi à fabriquer des fibres
pour le textile il faut en moyenne 6
flacons de liquide vaisselle pour
rembourrer un ours en peluche et le 27
bouteilles pour confectionner un pull
enfin avec les autres types de plastique
on fait des arrosoirs des sacs poubelles
des pare-chocs des bacs à compost mais
l'objectif aujourd'hui pour les
plastiques alimentaires c'est le
principe de la boucle fermée pour faire
simple qu'une bouteille en plastique
redevienne une bouteille en plastique
après recyclage c'est déjà le cas et ça
le sera aussi en 2025 pour nos pots de
yaourt ou même nos barquettes de jambon
vous le voyez certains plastiques
peuvent être recyclés mais ce n'est pas
le cas de tous du coup depuis 2021 de
nombreux produits de la vie courante en
plastique ne sont plus commercialisées
en France c'est le cas découvert des
pailles des gobelets des cotons-tiges et
de nombreux contenants alimentaires et
vous ne devinerez jamais avec quoi on
conçoit maintenant certains de ces
emballages avec du papier carton il est
renouvelable facilement recyclable sauf
qu'il a lui aussi ses limites il est
perméable à l'eau et au matières grasses
un handicap quand on souhaite emballer
des aliments il ne peut pas non plus
supporter des charges lourdes du coup
pour l'utiliser à la place du plastique
il faut le renforcer avec un film en
aluminium ou bien un film en plastique
ce qui complexifie le recyclage vous
faites Jamie il y a un autre matériau
dont on n'a pas trop parlé et qui
présente des avantages sur le plastique
et c'est le vert il représente à lui
seul 50% du poids de tous les emballages
ménagers c'est aussi d'ailleurs le
champion du taux de recyclage en France
88% par contre bah il y a aussi quelques
inconvénients quoi sont recyclage est
très énergivore pour recycler le verre
il faut faire chauffer la matière
jusqu'à 1000 degrés ce qui va alors
générer 350 g de CO2 la bouteille de
plus le transport du verre de le
protéger avec de l'emballage
supplémentaire pour éviter la casse et
comme c'est un matériau lourd bah il
oblige à consommer plus de carburant en
revanche un objet en verre peut être
réutilisé c'est le principe de la
consigne par exemple on rapporte au
commerçant le flacon vide et en échange
celui-ci nous donne une petite somme
d'argent cette démarche a déjà fait ses
preuves dans le passé elle revient en
force aujourd'hui et pas seulement pour
les boissons on trouve aussi des petits
pots pour bébé dans les emballages
consignes et sinon pourquoi pas faire
sans emballage et bien justement c'est
le principe du vrac les produits sont
vendus sans être emballé le client se
déplace avec son propre contenant
cependant aujourd'hui il n'existe pas
d'alternative vrac à tous les emballages
en plastique pour certains produits
frais ou liquides notamment bah ça reste
quand même la meilleure option on a
encore besoin du plastique pour faire
des emballages de médicaments pour
certains produits d'hygiène de shampoing
de savon liquide toutefois dans ce cas
précis on a toujours la possibilité
d'optimiser les emballages pour réduire
drastiquement la quantité de plastique
utilisé et là il suffirait de diminuer
l'épaisseur des emballages ou de réduire
les espaces vides pour demain certains
rêvent même d'un monde sans plastique
mais est-ce que c'est vraiment possible
malheureusement on en est encore loin
d'après un rapport de l'OCDE en 2060 les
êtres humains produiront et utiliseront
trois fois plus de plastique
qu'aujourd'hui nous consommons alors
plus de 1200 millions de tonnes de
plastiques chaque année sur une
population estimée à 10 milliards
d'habitants c'est l'équivalent de 65
sacs en plastique neuf par jour et par
habitant d'où l'importance du recyclage
mais pour qu'il soit efficace il faut
commencer par limiter notre consommation
de plastique et respecter les règles de
tri afin d'éviter qu'il finisse dans la
nature d'ailleurs les amis tu le sais
sans doute plusieurs initiatives
s'attaquent déjà à ce problème entre
océan cleanup plastique odyssée Marie
vierge en plastique il existe une
multitude de projet ayant pour objectif
de nettoyer les rivières et les océans
leur but capter les déchets et les
plastiques présents dans les eaux à la
sortie des égouts et avant même qu'ils
arrivent dans la mer et dans le genre
les cleanwalk sont très efficaces aussi
en fait ce sont des citoyens qui se
regroupent pour collecter manuellement
les déchets qui traînent un peu partout
sur les plages dans les rues dans les
parcs bref vous le voyez ça bouge et de
leur côté les pouvoirs publics ne sont
pas non plus en reste avec les lois
environnementales de plus en plus
strictes où la mise en place de taxes
plus ou moins lourdes en fonction de
l'impact des emballages utilisés là bah
c'est le principe de pollueurs payeur et
quant à nous les consommateurs nous
avons aussi le pouvoir de faire avancer
les choses en fait il y a plein de
possibilités rappelez-vous le meilleur
déchet c'est celui qu'on ne produit pas
choisir les produits avec le moins
d'emballage possible voire préférer le
vrac ou encore participer aux cleanwalks
donc n'hésitez pas à adopter des gestes
éco-citoyens si vous croisez un
emballage plastique qui traîne par terre
jetez-le au bon endroit le bac de tri
merci Chris pour cet échange si cette
vidéo vous a plu n'hésitez pas à liker
et à vous abonner si ce n'est pas encore
fait à revisionner aussi car il y avait
beaucoup d'infos ce n'est pas de l'usage
unique enfin si vous avez des idées de
sujets partagez-les en commentaire elles
seront étudiées avec soin allez à très
bientôt excellente fin de journée bonne
semaine et à dimanche prochain pour une
nouvelle vidéo épicurieuse
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]